sapphire and I realized that we have
white skin privilege and that we are
listened to carding is when the police
stop question and document and members
of our community it's racist and that
police officers tend to target black and
brown youth more than white here we're
in grade eight at city view alternative
senior school
we believe that carding is an oppressive
and dehumanizing acts that perpetuate
and awesome them relationship between
police and black or brown you
we're gonna be just telling people what
their rights are what carving is why
it's a problem raising awareness and
people have the right to ask if they're
being detained just to help things from
escalating or you being vulnerable or a
victim in any way if they're doing stuff
like this and actually getting involved
in doing things instead of starting a
Facebook group but actually getting on
the streets or talking to people that
that's very powerful if it's all I don't
be involved in this then nothing's gonna
really get diamond-making and lend as
much support as they want quit you can
actually do something about it